All right, so now we get to talk about science.
We get to talk about design.
We get to talk about DNA.
We get to talk about, well, let's be honest,
we get to talk about a lot of things.
Several of us probably don't have a ton of expertise in.
I mean, we talk about truth and logic
and even what our faith is.
That's sort of, for most of us youth leaders,
that's in our wheelhouse.
But when we get into things like science,
it gets a little bit more tricky.
You don't have to be an expert in this space.
But I want you to pay attention to a couple of things
and remember a couple of things
as you work through these next several weeks
focusing on things like science.
Our students are taught.
If you ask your students,
if you go into the public school classroom
and you look inside of what their textbooks say
and what teachers are saying
is this sort of separation between things of faith
and things of science.
We're told that these things don't belong together.
I remember even back when I was in seventh grade
many years ago, I was told by my teacher
when I looked up and I saw this chart
of a monkey suddenly becoming more and more
and evolving into a man,
I remember looking at that going,
how can that be?
I remember raising my hand and asking the question,
saying this doesn't seem right.
And I'll never forget what she said to me.
And it seemed to solve it for me.
And she said, I get what you're saying,
but that is religion and faith.
And this is science.
Even right there as a seventh grader,
the dichotomy, the split,
the two separate spheres of life were defined for me.
So for our students, that really is what's happening a lot.
And a lot of students are okay
and they're comfortable with that and that's fine.
But the more we research,
the more technologically advanced we become,
the more STEM research and STEM-like subjects
and careers become more popular
and much more pursued by our students post-college,
the more this separation is gonna get defined.
So it's crucially important that our students understand,
and guess what?
These two things don't actually need to be separated.
In fact, the more we discover through science,
the more we actually are gonna discover about God,
the more we discover how awesome he really is.
And over these next couple of weeks,
you're actually gonna start to see that.
So don't feel like you have to know all the science.
Don't run out to the library
and get a bunch of science books
and try to figure it all out.
I've tried.
Unless that's your thing, knock yourself out.
But for most of us, it's probably not a time thing we have,
nor maybe even the ability.
So don't worry about that,
but focus on getting your students to see
that these two worlds actually interconnect.
And I might even suggest
that find some of those students
who are really, really like amped up about science
and love it, whether it be math,
whether it be even computer technology,
anything in the biochemistry,
anything in the science world,
and get them switched on here and now.
This is a great way to get some of those students engaged.
So for this first week,
I think one of the crucial parts of your gathering
is gonna be your storyteller.
Really focus in on somebody
who can connect science and faith.
So I would suggest either find a university professor,
find somebody in the science field,
find somebody who actually does biology or chemistry
or some field in the sciences
that is in your church congregation
that can stand and for the students say here,
this is how I connect these two things together.
This is how I can see God
when I'm looking through a telescope or a microscope.
And this is how I can see God in the field of math
or whatever it might be.
It's hard.
And trust me, you're gonna need to sit down
and probably have a conversation
with the person that you'd like to do this
and make sure that they can comfortably make that connection.
I've even talked to Christian educators
who are math teachers and English teachers
and science teachers who even as their profession
have a really, really difficult time
sometimes making those connections.
I've done seminars with some teachers
and helping them to especially math teachers for some reason
to help them make that connection
so they can see their subject matter
through a biblical lens.
So make sure you sit down with those people
and help them see it if they don't already see it
but make sure that they can deliver that message
to your students because this is a crucial moment.
If your students can see that
from somebody else in your congregation
who actually does some of the jobs
that they might be pursuing down the road,
that's a huge, huge win for you
as you move forward in this study.
So in addition to the questions
that we've provided for you,
it would be a really, really good idea
for you to talk specifically with your students
about some of the school subjects
and some of the things that they're actually learning
in school.
So whatever they happen to be learning
at this particular time in their curriculum,
have them talk about that.
You might even have them bring in their textbooks.
Have them talk about what are the things
that they're learning so they can specifically tie in
the subject matter that they're dealing with in school
and their Christian worldview
so that you can help them make those connections.
Again, you don't have to know everything
about that particular subject.
You guys can work through that together.
In fact, it's a great opportunity
to have your students teach you
about what they're learning.
It's gonna help them learn it
and then you can help them see
the biblical worldview behind it.
So what we often forget is that in the school world,
and in a lot of our professional worlds too,
we have this thing called,
let me just go two different aspects of our world.
We have what's called the private sphere
and we have what's called the public sphere.
This is important to get.
If you think of this as a house,
and this is your upstairs where your bedrooms are
and what you think and what you do up in your bedrooms
is your private business, right?
Not many other people are gonna be up there
but when you have people over for company or whatever,
you have your public spheres.
This would be your kitchen, your living room
with those kinds of things.
These are two different spheres of life
and the things that you do here
are not the same as what you do here.
Oftentimes, the way we think is the exact same thing.
So what our students and sometimes us,
what we'll do is we'll put our school
or our jobs
in our public life
and we'll talk about some things specifically here
but then we'll put our Jesus life up in our private sphere
and we separate these two things
and we don't want them to connect
and we learn to live that way.
Just as I was taught in seventh grade,
this is exactly what my teacher was telling me to do.
Separate these two things,
live in a two-story home and leave it that way.
What we wanna do is we wanna get rid of this
and put Jesus down in our public space.
So here's the bottom line.
Science doesn't actually contradict our faith.
Instead, it lays a crucial foundation
for understanding our world.